and this is what people don't get to  decide to work from home early on in  their career if you decide to not come  to the office you don't have the  opportunity to overhear what your  colleagues are saying and maybe some  important meetings some important  customer conversations you don't have  the opportunity to have some informal  conversations with colleagues clients  suppliers and of course you don't have  the opportunity to build relationships  build networks even though this might be  in a popular opinion i do think that  working from home especially earlier in  your career will hurt your learnings and  will hurt your development in the long  term